[Musique]
professeur, tu vas avoir du mal à
croire que j'ai été envoyé ici pour toi dans
cinquante ans, donne-moi ça encore
une fois, s'il te plait, reste avec moi au
début, les Sentinelles ne ciblaient que
les mutants, puis elles ont commencé à
cibler tout le monde  J'ai parcouru un long chemin
pour nous guider pour rassembler les x-men
nous avons besoin de votre aide
dites à celui qui vous a envoyé je suis occupé
la personne qui m'a envoyé était vous
skurd nous a tous pris pour mettre fin à cette guerre
votre Bête  Je ne sais pas de quoi tu
parles assez fort pour un
enfant maigre J'ai dit que tu devais te quitter
et je vais être de bons amis tu
ne le sais pas encore
nous allons avoir besoin de mystique pourquoi tu es un
différent au cœur froid
où est Magneto cet homme est un monstre
il est détenu à une centaine d'étages sous
le bâtiment le plus gardé de la
planète Je connais un gars il serait un jeune homme
il est fascinant il est un emmerdeur
Prison Break c'est illégal  tu sais
seulement si tu te
fais prendre  ee toi aussi vieil ami
ça va être amusant
il y a un nouvel ennemi là-bas tu auras
besoin d'une nouvelle arme pour cette guerre
tout ce qui se passe maintenant
est entre tes mains
[Musique]
dans le futur je suis un enfant Non